so I want to welcome everyone for coming
out and thinking everyone for
participating in what is our second
annual Yale tech conference this is uh
yeah this is a pretty big event for us
being the second time we've thrown a
national event for Yale ease in the
technology space the first time we did
it was in San Francisco last year where
we had over 210 DS coming from as far
places as Shanghai and New York so we
decided to rotate it up this year and
come out to New York because we know
that there's a thriving community out
here it's just dying for more tech
events and better connections among
members of this community you know when
I started this about four years ago I
started organizing these first events it
was because I moved to San Francisco
with my startup paper G and it was
because I wanted to meet other Yale ease
in tech and I realized one thing I've
learned from yell if anything was to
meet people the best thing to do is
throw events how parties have drinks
have food and you start making friends
from that and so we started very small
with you know just my company and a few
other entrepreneurs on you and over time
that mushroomed really to hundreds of
people showing up regularly to San
Francisco events and at some point we
realized that this wasn't just a San
Francisco phenomenon but this was in
fact a nationwide if not global
phenomenon where people were interested
in tact they wanted to talk about tech
they wanted to meet other people in tech
and so we started putting these events
together and I'm really excited for this
year particular 2015 because we're
beginning to actually really see this
expand internationally so New York
certainly this was going to be our big
signature event this year but we're
seeing launches of Yale Tech in other
cities so we're already in San Francisco
Los Angeles and New York very strongly
but we're starting to see our first
event in London we're going to be seeing
events in China as well these are all
hosted by Yale entrepreneurs investors
and operators out of these cities who
want to see thriving yelled tech
communities out there so I would
encourage you to get involved in your
local chapters whether it's here in New
York or elsewhere if you're joining us I
really appreciate it if you're coming
from out of town and I would encourage
all of you to sign up
we have a website up now yell tech or we
r we have a mailing list to reach the
hundreds of people who have already
signed up actually now thousands of
people have now signed up for this
mailing list which will share news about
Yale ease in tech events coming up in
different cities will go out once a
quarter so we love for all you use join
us there on that website and for today
for throughout the conference we're
going to be using the hashtag yell tech
so if you're tweeting or using social
media feel free to tag us because we
definitely want to get the community not
just in New York talking about this but
anywhere yay lilly's really are so with
that I just want to thank our sponsor
goodwin procter which is a leading law
firm in the technology space they have
an amazing practice here in New York as
well as in Boston and San Francisco and
I want to hand it over now to jim boyle
who is the director of the EO
entrepreneurial institute I've known him
for many years now he's been at the
center of the ill text seen in fact in
many ways he's kind of started it on
campus at least from the University side
he's been one of the biggest advocates
for investing in Yale technol a leg as a
curriculum as a activity as really as a
community so I really want to welcome
Jim up onto the stage and have them talk
a little bit about the state about
yellow entrepreneurship